- If I was six foot four
and ran like a gazelle,
I'd play for the jets
instead of owning them.
I'd really need everybody
to have that one sink in.
Cause it's the most important one.
(upbeat music)
You know like when you're
driving and the cop lights go on
and that your fucking heart goes.
But then when the cop drives by,
you're like, Whoop!
You feel real good.
And then you start driving with two hands
and the speed limit
for about four minutes?
And then you go back to
being like ridiculous.
That's how people live
in their lives, right?
Like grandma gets sick
or mom has a cancer scare
or they get sick or something
and then they get start
caring about real shit.
Nobody's giving a fuck
about a supreme backpack
when your health isn't going anywhere.
And so I just don't understand why people
are living their lives like that.
And so fucking gratitude.
We've got the whole game misframed.
Everybody's confused.
People talking about millions.
As like, I gonna make a
million as like an entry point.
And they don't even
understand that 99% of people
in America, don't make $400,000 a year.
Nobody is putting on marathon sneakers.
Everybody wants to be a sprinter.
Everybody wants a tomorrow.
Lot of people taking money
and instead of investing
it back into their
business, buying dumb shit.
And that's why I fucking
put scrutiny on everybody
who's trying to do you know,
courses and pre-rolls try to get
you to pay 4,000 for this 10,000 for that.
All this is like, this shit is simple.
All the information is free.
There's a lot of people
who would much rather,
much rather pay somebody
to make them feel good
about why they're not doing.
Let me give you the secret
once and for all right here.
Work a lot.
Everybody looks at the people that made it
and none of you looked
at how they got there.
Talk your truth.
Create a framework that
you can fucking follow.
Talk your reality.
Think about your fucking grandparents,
they didn't have no internet,
they had to work the job and go to sleep.
The fact that you can
work from nine to five
to pay off your debt or
pay your rent or take care
of what you have to and then
you can take on your phone
and fucking work from 7:00
PM to two in the morning,
that's a fucking blessing.
That's a fucking opportunity.
And nobody can stop you
and nobody decides but us,
it's fucking crazy.
Do you have the humility to
putting the fucking work?
Period.
Because the only people
listening to your excuses
or your bullshit, are your
loser fucking friends.
My friends, let's just
get to the punchline.
Nobody gives a fuck about your problems.
People sit in little
circles of four people,
everybody gassing each
other up to not do shit.
People complaining downstairs
wearing $213 shoes.
Shut the fuck up.
Like keep perspective.
The fuck do you think is
going on in the world?
Everybody's pointing
at everybody else without understanding,
nobody's deploying empathy.
Here's what you don't get.
You fucking lack patience.
Too many of you talk about being it,
but you're not living it.
You know why you guys aren't patient?
Cause you wanna win already
to fuck and stick it,
to your fucking parents.
I'm trying to become
your excuse, your shield,
your thing that you can point to?
Because if you trip and fall,
you guys are worried about
failing and I'm trying to get
you to point at me and blame me,
that it didn't work
versus blaming yourself
so that it gives you the courage
to actually start doing shit.
But you've got to understand,
instead of sitting here and
dwelling and blaming them,
you're in control of your own shit.
You got one fucking that
bad, do something with it.
Listen, some of you've been consuming
this for a year or two,
you watched those videos
on Instagram or YouTube,
you watch my blog or this and that,
you get to listen to
podcasts, you get hyped.
You get hyped and you're like right
and then you stop
listening and you walk out
into your real life and
you go back to dumb shit.
You know when people
sitting here still dwelling
about some dumb shit
that happened in 2011?
It's binary.
This whole thing, your
fucking life, is binary.
Let me tell you what you should focus on.
You need to do some shit you like.
If I could ever convince all
of you that your shortcomings
and your detriments are your
strengths, you would win.
You guys wanna be selfless
and be good and get back?
Be selfish first to get your shit
to the place where you need to be.
The current state of political correctness
on how you should parent,
how you should live,
what age you should get married at,
like that's all bullshit.
Like there's only one story,
like yours.
I'm not scared of losing
because I don't allow any
of you to judge me.
Cause you're only scared to lose
cause you're worried about what
other people are gonna say.
My losses are my losses.
(car sirening)